und dann diskutieren wir gerade ob es in
deutschland eigentlich noch
meinungsfreiheit gibt unter anderem weil
der ex afg chef lucke immer wieder an
seinen vorlesungen an der uni hamburg
gehindert wird oder dort massiv gestört
wurde aber auch weil die deutschen
zuletzt in verschiedenen umfragen
mehrheit nicht geäußert haben man könne
bei uns nicht mehr alles sagen was ist
da dran
klarer fall für gernot hassknecht gernot
hassknecht erklärt meinungsfreiheit in
nur 140 sekunden leute hier geht ja
wirklich alles durcheinander ja was an
der uni hamburg mit luke passiert ist
war nicht in ordnung so helfen linke
idioten rechten idioten den mythos von
der verlorenen meinungsfreiheit zu
verbreiten vielen dank auch lasst ihn
doch seine vorlesung halten den bernd
lucke oder heißt der björn ansteigt
nicht mehr durch
meinungsfreiheit heißt ich darf alles
sagen was das strafrecht nicht verbietet
punkt was rechte darunter verstehen sie
wollen rassistische sachen sagen ohne
dass man sie einen rassisten nennt
sobald man sie dafür kritisiert oder
nicht ausdrücklich lobt leben wir alle
in einer diktatur so fühlt man sich bei
jeder demo als widerstandskämpfer du
bist auf eine meinung warum nicht aber
wenn ich was meine muss ich aushalten
was andere dann dazu mein meiner meinung
erschreckend wie die rechten bei uns
schon den diskurs bestimmen bleibt sich
ist politisch korrekt ein schimpfwort
was ist denn verkehrt daran minderheit
nicht zu diskriminieren muss ja jeder
mitmachen ist heute auch noch nicht
fortgeführt oder so
ja so weit sind wir nämlich schon in
dieser meinungsdiktatur dass man einen
morgen nicht mehr nennen darf
ich sage jeder der behauptet man darf in
diesem land nicht mehr alle sagen redet
quatsch und hilft den rechten ob er will
oder nicht sicher der ton ist verroht
dank internet was meinen sie was ich
diese sendung alles anhören muss von
hier und heute aus arnstadt auch beste
grüße an olivia welke und ihr team
olivia welt naja wenn er meint der
welche ist eine frau von mir aus ich
möchte den band sahnemixx fantasie auch
nicht kaputt machen jeder das geil
finden was er will hört auch zur
meinungsfreiheit hans de schreibt über
die heute show ihr seid die richtigen
links [ __ ] besonders welke die
stradivari unter den arschgeigen bei
euch smileys freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal